hello and welcome to this intelligence
squared plus online debate a sister
dying should be legalized
as you can imagine there is a lot of
disagreement on this issue which is why
tonight intelligence squared has brought
together four leading thinkers to debate
the emotion
assisted dying should be legalized
now before we start let me briefly
explain how it's all going to work
in a moment i'm going to ask you to make
your first vote on the motion
then our four debaters are going to make
their opening speeches after which i'll
be taking your questions and encouraging
some debate between the speakers
at about 6 55 pm the speakers will end
the debate with short closing statements
and then i will invite you again to make
your final vote which i will announce at
7 pm
now some of you may already have
questions in which case don't wait
please start sending them in to our
speakers now
how you may ask well if you look under
the video screen you'll see the ask
question button
click on it and then you can type out
your question and if you want to direct
it to a particular speaker just please
add their name at the beginning of your
question
then simply press send
and in addition
please make the conversation something
that you take to social media
you can tweet by using the hashtag iq
so
this is the moment when i'm going to ask
you to make your first vote
please vote now for or against the
motion
a sister dying should be legalized and
if you are unsure vote undecided
now while we wait for those votes to
come through if you've been following
the news at all then you will know that
there has been much debate in the uk in
recent years over issues concerning the
end of life and there are many strongly
held views on both sides of the debate
on position assisted dying
now some helpful
definitions are that assisted dying or
assisted suicide as it's also referred
to is where a doctor helps a patient to
kill themselves by prescribing a lethal
drug for the patient to take
now of course a sister dying by
definition is not a private act and
involves another person facilitating the
death of another
so friends relatives healthcare staff
and society are obviously affected by
the wider ramifications of this process
hence tonight's debate
now as we're still waiting for those
results of that vote to come through
let's just
yes here we are
so
your first vote is said
in favor of the motion eighty percent
against the motion five percent
and those undecided
fifteen percent
so interesting statistics there
now we're going to hear from our
speakers and their opening speeches
our first speaker for the motion is
anthony grayling
one of the uk's best known philosophers
and founder and principal of new college
of the humanities at northeastern
university he is the author of over 30
books of philosophy biography history of
ideas and essays he is an honorary
associate of the secular society and a
patron of dignity in dying
his latest book is the frontiers of
knowledge what we know about science
history and the mind
anthony
so we're debating the proposition about
assisted dying and that phrase is
important here so a little bit of
background is very interesting on this
topic and that is that back in 1962
suicide was decriminalized and it seemed
odd that prior to that time
um suicide was a criminal act but of
course only those people who failed in
their attempt to commit suicide could
get into trouble
but the decriminalization of suicide
implicitly perhaps even indeed
inarticulately recognized three
important principles
one of them is autonomy the fact that we
own
ourselves we own our own lives they
don't belong uh to the public or the
deity or something else they are our own
the second principle is the principle of
privacy the fact that there are some
decisions some
very very important moments in life that
are absolutely our own and dying uh is
one of those tremendously important and
very central facts of life
that belong to us and are our own to
decide about
and the final thing is it may seem
paradoxical this because you will
recognize that both autonomy and privacy
are enshrined in human rights uh
instruments of all kinds
and a very very important human right of
course is the right to life it may seem
a very odd one to invoke in this
connection but in fact a right to life
implicitly means a right to a minimum
quality of life it doesn't mean bare
existence it doesn't mean existing even
in great pain or in dignity or suffering
it means a minimum quality of life
and so the decriminalization of suicide
implied that autonomy privacy and a
right to a minimum quality of life are
principles which are very important for
a human being and human flourishing even
at the very end of life
what that um act in 1962 didn't do
however was
it didn't decriminalize anybody helping
somebody to die
and there are two important um
considerations here
as to why there should be a possibility
of assistance to somebody who wishes to
end his or her life the first is that a
suicide attempt might be botched and
might leave a person in a much worse off
condition than they were before
the second is there are people who
cannot commit suicide because perhaps
they are paralyzed they are suffering
some condition which makes it uh
impossible for them to get access to
means
to end their life or to just be
physically unable to do it and they
therefore need help
now medical science will make um dying
easy and peaceful and tranquil
and somebody who has a settled
clear-minded rational desire to
end life perhaps because their physical
or psychological suffering is
intolerable to them and their decision
is a rational care-minded one and a
settled one
it seems to be quite literally cruel to
deny help to somebody who needs help in
that situation to force somebody to
continue and prolong their suffering
their agony their indignity
because we are
not allowing people to help who have the
power to help
now i've noticed that
most of the
opposition to
assisted dying comes down fundamentally
to two things
one is the
anxiety about abuse
about people wanting to get rid of their
elderly relatives so they can get their
hands on the inheritance or perhaps
over stressed oppressed medical staff
wanting to clear a bed they know that
somebody
is
likely to die and perhaps in a couple of
weeks time and they want to help them
and move on
and this anxiety about abuse
is a great barrier to allowing people
who have chosen to end their lives or to
have help get help and have their lives
ended
is a great parish without happening
but if you look at the empirical data uh
in those jurisdictions where assisted
dying is legal uh you notice that um
scarcely anything uh in in the way of uh
discovered abuse occurs and indeed it's
much more likely that families anxious
not to lose a loved one are keeping
people alive who would very much prefer
to go early
the second
consideration which arises in this
connection
is that uh there is a kind of hidden
view
one not very often voiced but very
probably in the near background of those
people who are opposed to the assisted
dying and that is the idea that we don't
have a right to choose um about the end
of our life because our lives belong to
something else in fact there is a strong
religious element to this the idea that
our lives belong to the deity they're
given by god and they're
taken away by god and therefore we have
no right
to usurp that divine privilege
i notice that
many people who take that particular
view are also
quite happy about capital punishment and
war so it's not a very consistent
argument but at any rate it's one which
in our now secular age perhaps has lost
much of its force
and that
goody is my
opening statement
thank you so much anthony
our first speaker against the motion
is dr catherine sleeman
lang alaska chair and palliative care at
king's college london and an honorary
consultant in palliative medicine at
king's college hospital nhs trust
her research focuses on understanding
and improving care for people
approaching the end of life especially
older people and those with dementia
she leads several large research
programs including the maricuri-funded
better end-of-life project which
produces an annual state of the nation
report on dying death and bereavement in
the uk
catherine
thank you
well it's a great honor to be here
tonight in such distinguished company
i'm very aware that of all the panelists
i'm the one that no one's heard of so
why am i here well i'm here because my
career as a clinical academic is focused
on improving life for people who are
coming to the end of it
and i do that through research but also
through clinical care so i bring to this
debate decades of experience of
talking to sitting with holding the
hands of people during their final
illness exploring their symptoms and
concerns whether those are physical or
existential and then working to improve
them
now the question we are here to debate
isn't whether assisted dying is morally
okay and it's not whether assisted dying
is compassionate the question before us
is should it be licensed by law
laws exist to make society safer so to
answer the question we can't just focus
on autonomy privacy or even quality of
life
we have to consider the complex balance
of safety
and actually the fact is we just don't
have the autonomous right to many things
in medicine i mean i don't even have the
autonomous right to antibiotics when i
get a cough now that's not because of
the potential for harm to me
actually they might help me
it's because of the potential for harm
to society and i know from my clinical
work that there are people in our
society at risk of being harmed by a
change in the law
and here's the thing
the people i'm worried about they're by
definition lacking in autonomy they're
without a voice they can't tell us that
they're vulnerable or that they're being
coerced we don't hear from them in this
debate and i can guarantee you that none
of them are in the audience
the people i look after many are old
frail a bit confused they struggle to
navigate the health care system that
they find themselves in they're
increasingly reliant on other people for
everyday tasks and they already feel
much of the time that they are a burden
it's hard to think of a more vulnerable
population
because whatever anyone tells you this
law won't just affect a small number of
individuals people who've thought deeply
weighed up the pros and cons and can
articulate their views without external
pressure
legalization will affect everyone living
with a terminal illness who'll suddenly
be faced with a new option one that's
endorsed by society and within medicine
the nature bill currently going through
parliament has been spun as a modest
change
it's not
because it fundamentally changes how we
respond when patients tell us that they
don't think they can go on living
now this fundamental change may be
something that we society decide we want
but to know that we have to air
all of the complexities
not airbrush them
with appropriate safeguards is the
reassuringly simple phrase we hear all
the time but which safeguards are
appropriate and well how safe is safe
enough because no safeguards will be 100
safe
there will be people who slip through
the net so how safe is safe enough let's
quantify it
would we accept the death of one person
who didn't want to die in order to allow
the death of one who did
or maybe that ratio is one to ten
or is it ten to one
we have barely scratched the surface of
understanding the complexity here
we certainly haven't found the answers
of course we're told look at oregon
there's no evidence of abuse or harm
but did you know
that all of the information about safety
in oregon comes from a form
filled out by the doctor who wrote the
lethal prescription
after the person is dead with no system
for independent verification in 2020 one
oregon doctor wrote 31 lethal
prescriptions
and information on complications
associated with ingesting lethal drugs
was missing
in 71
of official cases
do we really want to base our law on
this
mental capacity an essential safeguard
can be affected by illness depression
medication
in ways that we are still learning about
data from oregon found that the
individual values of the doctors making
the capacity assessments determine the
outcome of that assessment
clinical reality doesn't always align
with neat boundaries
and it's in the gray areas that harms
will exist
one
really big grey area is how legalization
impacts on non-assisted suicides
there's some data that in jurisdictions
thank you there's some data
that in jurisdictions where assisted
dying is legal the rate of non-assisted
suicide has gone up not down
facts like this need to be scrutinized
and understood not swept under the
carpet
so the question we are here to consider
is not whether assisted dying is
compassionate whether it's morally okay
or whether we ourselves would want it
the question is should assisted dying be
legalized
laws exist to make society safer we have
to be sure that the risk of harm of
changing the law does not outweigh the
risk of harm of leaving the law as it is
now this condition may be met at some
point in the future but right now
it has not been and therefore i urge you
to oppose the motion
thank you
thank you catherine
our second speaker for the motion is
henry march cbe
he's a neurosurgeon whose work has been
the subject of two major bbc
documentaries his 2014 book do no harm
was an international bestseller and has
been translated into 34 languages
although retired from the nhs he
continued to work in countries including
the ukraine nepal pakistan and albania
until the start of the pandemic
in 2021 he announced that he has been
diagnosed with advanced prostate cancer
henry
well surprise surprise i'm going to talk
the second
the motion and i shall talk about this
personally even though professor
suleiman has said that's irrelevant to
the issue but i'll try to persuade you
otherwise to some extent
and i speak to you both as a doctor and
as you know as a patient who is
undergoing treatment for advanced
prostate cancer now neurosurgery is not
just surgery to the brain it's also
surgery to the spine and ironically
enough i must have operated upon
hundreds of old men like myself with
prostate cancer because it typically
spreads to the spine and causes
paralysis
surgery
delays that but usually doesn't actually
ultimately stop it
so the the end stage for many patients
the prostate cancer which may well apply
to me
is is paralysis and double incontinence
in institutional care
and personally that is a prospect i view
with dread as i think most people would
now the point is that good palliative
care does not invariably abolish
suffering for people who are dying or
suffering intractably from some
degenerative disease
because
dying is is not just the matter of pain
as many people seem to think it is but
but even that sometimes is not very
effectively dealt with but of course
palliative care the hospice movement
originates in this country is something
we should all be proud of and we need
more of it and there should be more
funding for it and the legalization of
assisted dying would need not despite
what some people say and act against
that
but the fact of the matter is dying can
often involve great misery and a lot of
dignity and autonomy but is not
addressed by good parts of care
in oregon interesting enough um a survey
of people who opted for assisted dying
showed that 94
cited a lack of enjoyment of life 93
loss of autonomy and 72 loss of dignity
and the survey published in canada
covering last year showed that 82
percent of people requesting assisted
dying had received palliative care and
as far as i know palliative care and
calendar is pretty good
and nevertheless wanted his sister dying
and and also it was easily accessible to
the remaining 18
and again the evidence from all these
countries and there are many of them now
where assisted dying is legalized is the
numbers of patients we're talking about
are quite small one in a thousand deaths
in oregon holland is is a bit of an
outlier with five and a hundred deaths
but that's dutch culture if you know
holland as i do is rather different from
the reticent english
the fact of the matter is i don't want
to end my life in a hospital or hospice
bed paralyzed and doubly incontinent
like most people i want to die at home
at a time of my own choice with my
family around me which is what my family
will want as well
but the english law requires that i
suffer
and many of my poor patients suffer
even though suicide is not against the
law now professor schliemann i'll quote
that's written in the bmj my quote none
of us has your autonomous right to rob a
bank or even to receive antibiotics as
she just said now when we have a cold
not because of the potential harm to our
souls but because of the potential
potential harm to others
but where is the evidence please that
saving people from suffering will harm
others where is the evidence
besides autonomy in the context of a
sister die is not about the right to do
anything i want but about the right not
to have to suffer
anyway it's illegal to rob a bank and
therefore illegal to help somebody do it
but suicide is not illegal and
antibiotics is simply the wrong
treatment for a cold anyway most of the
time so how can it be but it's against
the law to help somebody to do something
that is not against the law
now the opponents to assist to dying as
you've heard say that vulnerable people
will be coerced into killing themselves
and the palliative care will suffer if
people are persuaded or coerced by
greedy uncaring relatives or cruel
carers and health professionals in dying
prematurely they have a glib sound bite
right to die will become duty to die but
fail to point out the corrory which is
no right to die means duty to suffer
but if i am to suffer when i'm dying
possibly paralyzed and doubly
incontinent i won't really cast iron
evidence that my suffering and misery
isn't a good cause and will prevent
suffering for other people so where is
this evidence as a judgment stephen
sidley has recently argued the current
law in england recognizes no difference
between helping somebody who is
suffering greatly and who requests
assisted dying and actually encouraging
somebody to kill themselves
this is clearly absurd especially as the
law is a mysterious crime act of 2015
there's no difficulty in recognizing
coercive behavior
the whole point about assisted dying i
can't emphasize this point enough is
that in all jurisdictions it comes
through safeguards essentially with the
applicant's mental capacity and is not
being coerced as judged by an
independent expert or experts exact
details of safeguards vary from country
to country if you don't like the oregon
safeguard so we could have different
safeguards in this country
and as a recent leader in the economist
three weeks ago and i'll quote in places
of the longest experience of assisted
dying charities that represent the
elderly or disabled have not reported
any abuse
in america the netherlands and
switzerland the overwhelming majority of
those who choose an assisted test are
educated and middle class in short
they're not vulnerable people at the
bottom of the social ladder
what is the alternative for people in
this country who don't have the minimum
ten thousand pounds or physical capacity
to go to switzerland the answer is
unassisted suicide 300 people a year in
the uk with terminal disease kill
themselves violent and terrible for the
family solitary in secret even though
perfectly legal and effectively
encouraged by the current law
thank you
and now our last speaker against the
motion anne atkins
author and journalist who has written
four novels a play and several books of
nonfiction as well as contributing
chapters and introductions to many more
she has contributed to all the major
national newspapers and written regular
columns in the daily telegraph and daily
express
she's also working on a first folio
edition of a midsummer night's dream for
children
she's a regular contributor to the today
program and thought today to to the
today's program thought for the day
and
thank you
as a christian i have no intrinsic fair
fear of death it heralds freedom to a
far better future for me so death isn't
the problem to me that it is for others
i have sympathy for this motion
my opposition is
not philosophical far less theological
but practical pragmatic and above all
personal
my parents came to live with us 12 years
ago and to our great sorrow my mother
died
from which moment
my father ticked all the boxes for
assisted death he longed to be with her
for months intermittently years he
railed against life he certainly had
full capacity and a horror of being a
burden and on the advice of doctors i
had him registered for end-of-life care
specifically for people approaching
death
definition expected to die within six
months within six months which therefore
he was
expected to
a few years later in 2015 i was with him
when his pulse was measured as 17 the
first thing he asked the consultant is
there anything you can do for me
the man who wanted to die and my mother
did
a few years after that the gp gave him
the option of being admitted to hospital
which he loathed and hated
or staying at home and
died
the person who in 2009 had raged against
life in 2019
chose life
when he turned 100
70 former pupils celebrated with him in
the school he used to run and the
composer bob chilcott wrote a song for
him
43 other pupils
put on a lunch for him in the cambridge
college they all followed him to and a
different hundred friends came to a
party in our garden and we had nearly as
big a celebration for his 102nd birthday
on the 12th of march
2020 he had a long interview for a
program now available on channel 5 the
secrets of world war ii
and that evening he and i resumed our
studies of enid 6 he having enabled my
lifelong ambition to study greek and
latin literature
the next day friday he went to bed early
and by saturday he was complaining that
dying was taking a very long time he was
always impatient
on monday
he joined my mother 12 years after he
first said he wanted to
in his last decade of life he appeared
on numerous television programs on the
today program twice on radio 2 at
christmas and various local stations and
was interviewed for inclusion in a
number of books every remembrance day he
addressed school children about his
experiences as a conscientious objector
he taught almost every day and he turned
around
the life for somebody crippled by
depression who's now studying south
korea on placement from so as he gave
the reading at our daughter's wedding in
greek then in english and sang a solo
and he swam in the north sea until his
pacemaker at the age of 98
the person who never wanted to become a
burden
i can't see any protection for my father
in this bill in the rawness of his grief
compass mentis expressing the will to
die
and deemed nearly dead anyway
i would have lost my best years with him
and our son-in-law and grandson wouldn't
know him
now look we object to rightly to capital
punishment on the grounds that in case
despite years of evidence and trials and
judicious processes and appeal
there might be one wrong death
so go figure
our daughter is in her 30s one of the
most gifted talented and charismatic
people i know
and last year for her birthday she
requested a trip to dignitas
her life is one of almost continuous and
she would say unbearable agony
devastated by mental illness she has
expressed the wish to die frequently
over the last 20 years can you imagine
telling her this bill is not for her
that physical anguish qualifies but not
mental torment that it's available for
my father whose pain would have been
over soon anyway but not for her who
might have 60 more years of it
and thank god
it's not
yet
of course she deserves an end to her
pain
she needs mental health care to be
researched funded understood and taken
seriously yes we could give her a much
quicker and easier answer and not bother
which she believes is why mental health
care isn't funded because it's cheaper
to let sufferers kill themselves
several people i love very dearly have
been distressed enough to die
and endorsing such dreadful despair
inevitably blunts the search for the
real answer
in my last summer term at oxford i saw a
tarpaulin heaped at the foot of the
university church police cordons
ambulance flashing i couldn't understand
how exams could be more important than
life
until age 10
our aspergic son climbed up on the
school roof to do the same he couldn't
do what teachers kept demanding of him
fortunately nor could he be sure he'd
succeed and being in a wheelchair would
have compounded his pain
the next night i quoted lord jacobits
taking life is wrong
your own
or anyone else's
years later he told me that statement
changed him forever
having ruled out that solution he looked
for others school continued impossible
he failed his exams he was thrown out of
cambridge he had to start all over again
behind all his peers but he kept saying
it doesn't matter
i've kept the conflict
i'm
alive
he's now extremely successful
extremely happy
and still
alive
and i want the same for my daughter
so you've heard now from each of our
speakers powerful testimony from each of
them
it's now your turn
what questions have their thoughts
raised for you
share them with us now
click on the ask a question button under
your video screen and remember to add
the name of the speaker
if you want to direct your question to
anyone in particular and please don't
forget to tweet us using the hashtag iq2
now listening to each of our speakers
has raised a number of issues for me and
as a clinician who admittedly works in
pediatrics and doesn't generally have to
deal with questions at the end of life
in the same way as those who work with
adult medicine do
it still raised a number of questions
for me and as we are waiting for some of
these questions to come through i
wondered if i could actually kick things
off
by asking about
some of the philosophical concepts that
have come up today we've heard about
autonomy
this idea of justice to those who
would like this to be offered to them
but we've i also wonder whether
the call for a sister dying is actually
a radical call to increase patient
empowerment
the public have been in favor of a
sister dying for a number of years now
and if anything it's the medical
profession that's lagging behind
and i guess my question to all speakers
here would be why is this
what is it about the medical profession
that makes us hesitant to back such a
bill
is this paternalism in play
and is this a bid to hold on to medical
power even at the end of life
i don't know if any of our speakers
would like to chip in with an answer
there
it's very very frightening you might be
wrong i had to make
hundreds of life and death decisions
about whether to treat people
with where the serious brain injuries or
not i was just talking about it this
morning when i was teaching my trainees
and i said they ring me at night with a
sharing a brain scan over the internet
of somebody with a with a potentially
fatal hemorrhage
um
if i say operate i get back to sleep
if i say they don't the chances are the
patient will be left dreadfully disabled
which is often the case i don't get back
to sleep
and because i'm worried i might be wrong
and this is one of the reasons why
there's so much over treatment
in in modern medicine particularly in
neurosurgery because we're so frightened
about about missing
missing a savable life but it comes at
the cost you know we all have a story
case this morning which was
in my opinion crazy but my colleague had
operated in the middle of the night um
and the patient may survive but there's
no possibility at all of any sort of
quality of life these are incredibly
difficult decisions and most doctors
you know run the cover it's always
easier to treat than not to treat
catherine yes i wondered whether you
would want to come in on that question
thank you a couple of things i just want
to pick up on public opinion and then
i'll talk about doctors and and how they
feel so it's true that in a lot of
opinion polls we hear this statistic oh
80 to the public want this
but actually um
if you provide the public with more
information about what assisted dying
actually is you find that support drops
and there was one poll that found you
know initially 75 percent of the public
said yes i want to leave we should
legalize assisted dying
about 40 percent of the same people
subsequently change their minds simply
when some of the theoretical arguments
are set against were um presented to
them there was also a public opinion
survey this year that asked people
whether or not they supported assisted
dying and then said oh by the way what
do you understand by the term assisted
dying more than half of the people who
responded to that survey incorrectly
picked the definition of assisted dying
out of a list of three things the other
two things were currently um legal good
practice end-of-life care like having
the um ability um the being able to um
say no to treatments that might extend
your life so although we hear a lot oh
the public want this actually if you
unpick those statistics they're not
quite as strong as we're led to believe
in terms of doctors i think
what i think is very interesting is the
difference among doctors within
different medical specialties so the bma
british medical association did a survey
in 2020 that basically said are you in
favor of assisted dying and i think 37
of doctors across the board said yes but
if you split those doctors into
different professional groups
there was a huge variation with at one
end of the spectrum ear nose and throat
surgeons who were most strongly in favor
and at the other end of the spectrum
palliative care doctors like me followed
by care of the elderly doctors who were
most um against
i mean i would suggest that the reason
that palliative care doctors and care of
the elderly doctors at that end of the
spectrum is because we have first-hand
experience every day of caring for
people who are old frail deteriorating
and at an extremely vulnerable time of
life
the bread and butter of my job is
communication it's talking to people
about their wishes values hopes their
fears and i think many doctors who look
after people at this phase of life which
is essentially most doctors
have seen people with what at first
glance it seemed like insurmountable
distress find meaning and comfort and
peace through high quality care whether
that's palliative care or something else
that is that is an argument that is an
argument for a time delay there's no an
argument against the sister dying per se
in canada i think the latest legislation
if you apply for if you ask for a sister
dying on the grounds of intractable
suffering it's mandated you have
palliative care and it's mandated you
have a 90-day it's not
it is not it's not no it's mandated that
that is offered to you quote if it's
available so it's about a 90-day what
about the 90-day delay
so there is a 90-day delay for people
who are whose deaths are not reasonable
reasonably foreseeable for people whose
deaths are reasonably foreseeable and i
would suggest that is an enormous number
of people because of the such vague
wording there is you can have an um your
lethal medication or your injection on
the day that you request it so that's
not correct but are you saying there are
no possible safeguards
i mean you you may criticize safeguards
in the various countries but
i'm going to step in here
thank you thank you
clearly this is a very heated topic and
clearly there's also
what's what's being illustrated there's
actually there's a lack of information
isn't there for the public and even for
people of professionals in in who work
in medicine
um anthony you've had your hand up would
you like to respond to what's just been
said yes yes indeed well i have the very
greatest admiration for the kind of work
that uh professor schliemann does and
the hospice
service does it it's wonderful
but i'm afraid with great respect
professor lima she really is confusing
the issue here tremendously yes indeed
there are many elderly vulnerable
confused people and there can be no
question whatever that anybody can
bring
the life of such a person to an end
because such a person has no
clear rational uh settled intention to
die this this is uh
about
people who really understand the issues
uh who can uh establish that they are
rational and clear-minded about it and
that the intention in question is
settled because there has to be today of
some um weeks this is what the current
legislation is suggesting and there have
to be more than one doctors involved in
saying that they are
satisfied that the intention is clear
and settled so we're talking about um
you know a very different group of
people from the ones that catherine
schliemann is talking about and we're
talking about people who wish to
exercise their autonomy their right they
own their lives and they are the ones
who are the best judges by far
of uh the quality of their life
catherine this looks like you want to
respond thank you and if i may um so i'm
not saying that there are not a small
group of people exactly as you described
fully autonomous have been thinking you
know weighed up the pros and cons and
for them i'm actually not going to say
that it is not the right thing it i
think unless they're my patient or my
close family member who am i to judge
that what i'm saying is that there is a
broader question here and i would love
i would love to hear your views on the
issue of how safe is safe enough do you
agree with me that no safeguards will be
a hundred percent safe and if so please
tell me how safe you think is safe
enough for this law
well look the parallel here is um
current suggestions about voter id
because there have been a couple of uh
cases of fraud at election time among
millions of those cards and and
therefore everybody has now if you come
under this prescription that you cannot
vote unless you can produce a passport
or whatever in other words it's you know
and
it's the reverse of shoot all the dogs
because one dog has bitten somebody and
and
making um public legislation turn on the
fact that there is
very very small numbers of people very
very small possibilities of abuse
is quite the wrong way to approach the
question this is really a question about
our compassion towards people whose
suffering is from their point of view
intolerable
and as is often said and it's a crude
way of putting the point but it's all
too true unfortunately we're quite
frankly kinder to our dogs than we are
to our fellow human beings who are
suffering
i i think anne wanted to respond there
so
i'm a bit kind of flabbergasted to be
honest that you can compare
voter id having
votes cast erroneously with somebody's
life being taken arranged i can't quite
believe don't jump on that particular
kind of
thing
i said it was a it was a parallel of
taking a very small number of cases and
applying it to millions of cases
i totally understood that but the
parallel between having people cast
their vote erroneously and having
somebody lose a life erroneously the
fact that you can make that a parallel i
find shocking but anyway what i was
going to go on to say was that within
four years of the the law changing in
holland it was deemed that around three
quarters of people who had had a sister
die were not in a position to have been
able to choose how how can you reconcile
that with some of the things you're
saying i don't i i'm
stumped
i i think just to move the discussion on
a bit and actually to to refer to some
of the questions that we're getting
there are questions here about the
evidence around this and it sounds like
both sides have evidence which falls in
their favor and so i'm really interested
in digging down into this
um people want to know what evidence is
there
in terms of
where this has already been legalized in
terms of the extra pressure that people
will be feeling to to end their lives
and on the flip side when when we hear
that actually in places where it has
been legalized there haven't been any
abuses of the system whatever what
evidence do we have for that so that
there are two things and both sides
please feel free to respond
well i'll just read the rest of the
quotation from the economist where it
says
it is conceivable that some abuse has
taken place unobserved but scrutiny the
economist says has been intense and in
most countries permission to help
someone die is revoked if there is a
hint of
coercion and that is what the economy
says
um i think catherine knows more about
this than i do but catherine um
could you tell us who is it who judges
that there have been no abuses
who put out the
i think it's different in different
jurisdictions um i know know most about
oregon we we all know most about oregon
because they've had their law for
longest almost two decades now um there
information about safety is as i said um
earlier collected on a form
filled in by the physician who wrote the
lethal prescription after the person's
dead and with no independent
verification so
personally i don't think that's good
enough to tell us whether or not there
has been um
tell us anything and actually what it
did tell us last year is that for 71 of
people who had an assisted death there
was no information on the safety the the
complications associated with ingesting
the medication i think there is a world
of difference between stating
straightforward conditions that sound
very nice on paper and producing
safeguards that really do stand up to
the pressure of the real world i mean to
rattle off some of the safeguards that
are proposed in the nietzsche
legislation first of all the six-month
prognosis rule which i suspect everyone
agrees with me
makes i mean it makes legislation more
palatable perhaps but certainly it is
completely flawed as a safeguard it's
arbitrary there's nothing special about
six months it's impossible and i know
that from a decade of being asked
frequently how long have i got doctor
and it's actually discriminatory as ann
was suggesting why would we
propose a law that discriminates against
people with the most slowly progressive
conditions
capacity um as i suggested comes down to
the individual doctor there and of
course you have to get capacity for two
from two doctors yes that sounds very
good but if one of them says no i don't
think this person has capacity the
person is entirely able to go to the
next doctor and the next doctor and the
next doctor until one who says they do
and one doctor last year in oregon wrote
31 prescriptions it's impossible to
mitigate against that okay look we're
having
you know the the um
the the argument being put here is that
in case there are some abuses in case
there are some abuses nobody shall be
helped if they are suffering intolerably
and i mean this just seems to me to be
quite literally a cruel argument because
it dismisses
a whole range of considerations about
about people like myself for example i'm
signed up with dignitas if i were to be
uh in the the position uh of uh somebody
who likely to be paralyzed or to suffer
or
to have an appalling um last year of
life being doubly incontinent and so on
i should very very much rather have a
peaceful and tranquil way of leaving and
i would love to be able to do it in my
own home with the people i care about
instead of having to travel abroad or
attempting to do it myself without
really the proper facilities for it so
the risk the risk the tiny risk that
there might be abuse
allowing you
to to say i am not allowed to have that
help that at best i can try to do it
myself because suicide itself is not
illegal seems to me to be frankly
uncompassionate
i'm not saying and then we need data we
don't have the data we don't have that
quantification and isn't that essential
before putting this law through because
laws after all are there to make society
safer don't we need to know how safe
this law is
that argument cuts both ways because you
cannot produce evidence that there is
sufficient abuse to make it a really
serious anxiety that this is insane and
actually
thank you anthony i i just want to to
feed in another question from the
audience who touch on that point and it
is it is for you catherine is how will
we know when we have reached the point
in the future when there would be no
risk of harm by
legalizing assisted suicide
i don't think we will ever um that's the
point we'll reach there will never be no
risk of harm right and we accept risks
of harm in everyday life all the time so
that's not what that's not what we're
aiming for what we need to know is how
great is the risk of harm and
what risk of harm does
wood society accept here we put all this
emphasis on 80 of the public supports it
but the public supports it assuming
there is no harm so let's have that
societal conversation let's say really
go into the murky area of what the harms
might be and for whom and ask the public
again you know help us legislate in a
way that suits you rather than sweeping
everything under the carpet in this
sterilizer it's all going to be
perfectly safe so
how can we
how can we assess the risks without
legalizing it carefully collecting the
data reviewing what happens and then
adjusting the safeguards accordingly
until then it's a purely theoretical
exercise and the other point is every
time i operate in almost all the
operations i did had a
significant risk of the patient dying or
being left with serious damage but you
justified that risk on the grands a much
greater number of people benefited and
us don't see why that utilitarian ethic
should not apply and medicine is all
about experimentation we know that and
in effect your argument i agree with we
need to experiment with assisted dying
we need to legalize it with strict
safeguards and then see how it goes and
adjust it as necessary and that is the
only way we can find out that
for certain whether in fact large
numbers of people are being coerced or
not
and i think you had your hand up sure
i think we're all being a little bit
sort of myopic on this and focusing on
individual cases we're focusing on
either somebody who wants to die and
somebody doesn't want to die and the
mistakes we make what we're ignoring is
is the broad brushstroke of what it's
going to do to our attitude to society
if we endorse it so at the moment you
know if a friend of yours is hanging off
clifton bridge you run forward and say
don't do it don't do it let's make your
life worth living let me help you let me
help you to live let me help you to
solve your problems this is this is you
know the instinctive urge of all of us
that life is worth living we must help
you make your life worth living as soon
as you
you stamp approval
on
giving up because your life isn't worth
living it changes
it changes society's attitude in a way
that we're all ignoring if i go back to
my daughter
as i say she is she at the moment is
going through unbearable suffering now
if society says instead of fixing your
suffering let's give up
then i i i'm terrified for her life
because i don't think you know i
i'm not at all convinced she would still
be alive today um we're all ignoring
that we're looking at these tiny little
cases of everybody you know over 75 or
with a terminal illness or whatever
whatever we're ignoring
what this says to suicidal teenagers
what this says to our friend who thinks
he can't go on what you know there will
be a seismic shift
in the way we view suicide
if we say we endorse it
so let's let's pick up on that topic
about what society thinks and the kind
of debate that we might or might not be
having at a national level and i want to
pick up on two things
something that henry just said which was
um
about the idea that we should experiment
with a sister dying as a way of
understanding whether this is the right
thing for society which is an
interesting
proposition and also catherine what you
said and you've said a number of times
now which is that
at a national level we haven't dealt
with death we don't talk about it and we
certainly are not talking about the
complexities of this particular issue in
any meaningful way other than in this
debate so
i want to talk about this issue how do
we have a debate that does open
this to the public not not to the people
who are here at the moment but to the
general public
and another thing and one of the
questions that has been brought brought
up by what somebody and i hasten to add
in the audience is the demographics here
it's a privileged class who are talking
about this at the moment
and
what is it about uh the way that we're
having this discussion which will
actually only further exacerbate
inequalities
so there's a it's a it's a big question
that i'm asking but how do we have this
conversation in society and how do we
make sure that whatever happens as we go
forward
it doesn't
worsen inequalities that are already in
existence in our health system
catherine looks like you're ready to
answer
in order to to be clear and focused
about what's really addressed you here
and thinking about
the fact that pretty well every
exercise of autonomy across the whole
range of human activity
it carries its its risks with aware of
it getting into a motor car getting into
an airplane and so on the public policy
issues
have to account for um what's in the
public interest uh what what kind of
safeguards are proper to put in place
for pretty well anything that people
do in society and the impact that it has
on other people and at the same time
certain principles have to be honored
one very very central principle is this
a principle of autonomy
and of
privacy and the fact that life's quality
is a much more important consideration
than quantity now a lot of what's what's
been said by and in particular but also
katherine this is slippery slope
fallacies that uh if you allow this then
there's going to be you know some
tremendous cascade of i don't think i've
said that at all i don't think i've
referred to this it doesn't seem to be
any evidence of that in all the other
jurisdictions where that this has
happened so far and because as henry
says there has been a great deal of
scrutiny about the application of these
things and again it has to be remembered
we're talking about people who make the
decision in a clear-minded and rational
and settled way it's not about other
people who might be confused or
vulnerable and one final point that has
to be remembered is
that in just so long as uh helping
someone to die remains illegal
then there'd be plenty of cases maybe
thousands of cases every year all around
our country where compassionate medical
professionals do
help people to die and but put
themselves at risk when that happens
catherine
well i mean too much to pick up on i'm
going to come back to your questions
goody um the societal aspect and how we
have the conversation i think is really
important
our society has become a lot less
familiar with death it's possible to
reach well into adulthood without having
really experienced deaths my experience
having cared for hundreds if not
thousands of dying people is death is
usually peaceful but of course none of
us have gone through it so who are we to
know and i i do think a fear of dying
drives a lot of this societal
conversation
and your point about ethnicity
about inequality sorry is
absolutely key yes it's true the people
who reveal themselves of an assisted
death are usually um quite sort of
middle-class
socio-economically not deprived but
actually we know that there are huge
gaps in terms of provision of palliative
care for example people who are
socioeconomically deprived and in ethnic
minority communities are less likely to
get palliative care
and i think that and there are hundreds
about a hundred thousand people who die
every year in this country who need
palliative care but don't get it
legalizing assisted dying without
ensuring that high quality palliative
care is available to everyone sends a
really dangerous message i think to
people who are terminally ill well you
can't have palliative care but here you
can have this
i am going to have to
draw this conversation to a close
but what i do want is for our speakers
now to make up their summing up speeches
they each have a minute in order to
convince you
and we're going to go in reverse order
to the way that we started so to begin
ann could you start with your summing up
speech sure as i said at the outset i
have considerable sympathy for those
wanting to die my faith teaches me
compassion as well as that death isn't
the end and of course
living
is always more painful than dying i'll
just let my clock finish striking
yeah living is always more painful than
dying of course it is
but we all know that for those this bill
purports to serve the law is already
compassionate no one is prosecuted for
genuine acts of love and mercy so it's
disingenuous at the best to pretend that
this bill is for them or that the
safeguards are there to stay
its proponents openly admit they simply
see it as a first step to make assisted
dying more widely available as has
happened in every country
so far that has introduced it what it
will do is approve society suicide
society's ultimate failure towards the
suffering
our daughters are several friends to
help her die
make despair acceptable and one of them
will
why should she die
because we can't be bothered to help her
live
because it's cheaper to enable death
than life
because we'd rather end her life than
her suffering
and that's something i will fight for
till the end of mine
thank you
henry
where assisted dying is now
legal it seems that abuse is pretty
unlikely and unusual
therefore i feel very strongly the only
way to answer these questions is by
legalizing it in this country
and then and carrying out a medic an
experiment all medical progress is based
on experimentation it may sound rather
brutal and callous but i think it's very
unlikely
that legalizing a sister dying would
lead to a great abuse
therefore it should be legalized
very careful with careful safeguards
and rewrite into the legislation that it
will be reviewed and the legislation is
not automatically reviewed
i don't really see how that could go
very wrong
thank you and
for your final intervention catherine
please
consider that this law won't just affect
a small number of individuals
if we legalize assisted dying then
almost everyone in their lifetime would
be presented with this new option of
whether or not to end their lives now
yes this includes people like us
strong minded individuals thinking
deeply about the issue
but it also includes people who are
distraught and confused people with
profound misconceptions about dying and
people with conditions and treatments
that affect their mental capacity in
subtle ways
a vote against the motion is a vote for
more evidence better scrutiny of
unintended harms and quantification of
the risks before any experimentation
without experimentation so i'm just
going to end with a
question what is worse
killing someone who really wants to live
or not killing someone who really wants
to die if you think that the former is
worse then i urge you to oppose the
motion
thank you and finally anthony
well for me uh uh it comes down to a
question really of our respect for uh
others and our compassion for those who
who suffer and the vast majority of us
want to live and the vast majority of us
would
continue to want to live even if we were
suffering but for people whose suffering
is intolerable and henry is right it's
not just pain it's in dignity it's being
um
incontinent and and
very dependent on on others and hating
that dependence and we're not talking
about people here the kind of people
invoked all the time by professor
scheming people who are
confused and vulnerable it's not about
them this is something which gives a
respect for the
choice that people make about their own
lives given that they're the ones who
are delivering it and suffering it and
you've made up their minds about what
they would like to do about it
in classical antiquity it was regarded
as honorable to um take your life if you
were
quite sure that you didn't want to
continue living it was regarded as
something that had
rather large degree of courage and
nobility about it and when that is the
case for those very very few individuals
relatively speaking because we're
talking about very small numbers of
people here who want that then it seems
to be the grossest form of paternalism
to say no you're not allowed we're not
going to allow you to do that there you
are you're suffering you're you're uh in
this intolerable situation for you but
we're not going to help you and that
ultimately seems to me to be unkind so
fundamentally the issue here is one of
compassion and respect for for our
fellows
if they are genuinely in a position to
make that choice
there you are you've heard from all of
our speakers and it's now time for you
to make your final vote on the motion
a sister dying should be legalized
please vote for or against the motion
and if you still haven't made up your
mind vote undecided
now while all of that is happening and
while you are making your final
decisions i'm reflecting on
how emotive this topic is on how
exercise each of us became in that
debate
how for me there are these different
polls that we're dealing with here we've
got autonomy on the one side and the
autonomy of the patient
versus
the patient safety question and what
this means for us as a population and it
is very much the individual versus the
population
here but there's also this idea of
quantity of life versus quality of life
and these are questions that i don't
think
as a society we have grappled with yet
because we haven't had the kinds of
debates that are required for this uh
yet at a national level and so
it's really interesting to hear our
speakers today battle it out in this way
so please put your votes
under the under the uh video box please
and hopefully we'll be getting with some
results soon
it looks like we've got a result ah so
the final vote is
in favor of the motion 75
no 15
and undecided 10 percent so there's been
a little bit of a shift
it looks like
um those against the motion were able to
persuade a few people onto their side
but we still have an overwhelming
majority of people who
motion
i'd like to take this opportunity to
thank each of our speakers all four of
them have delivered brilliant speeches
tonight and we're very very grateful to
them for their time